when you're 18 to lose like this and
realize that you're not Untouchable kind
of changes a Fighter's path so for Rosa
Junior it's okay to lose an MMA he
shouldn't hang his head the issue is at
18 this early in your career was he
seven and one eight and one now so you
don't have a ton of fights you don't
have a ton of big moments in your career
there's a reason why boxers are 30-0
25-0 45-0 by the time they really face
any adversity because if you look at
like a guy like Mike Tyson they they
need to get to a certain level where
they actually think they're God's Gift
of fighting and they go in there with
that mindset thinking they can pull
anything off but that's done through
actual fighting it's not done through
words your coaches tell you that or your
training Partners telling you that you
actually got to get it done inside that
out gun or inside that ring through
years of experience